♪ ♪
>> Greg: WE AT "THE FIVE" LOVE
A GOOD COOKING SEGMENT.
WHO DOESN'T LOVE A DELICIOUS,
MOUTHWATERING STEAK LIKE THIS
ONE.
WATCH IT BEING LOVINGLY PREPARED
BY A 3D PRINTER.
THE CHEF IS A FACTS MACHINE WITH
A NOZZLE.
WORSE, IT'S A VEGAN STATE, NOT
MADE FROM VEGANS.
THE INK FROM THE CARTRIDGE IS
MADE FROM RICE, PEAS, AND
SEAWEED.
YES, SEAWEED.
WHO NEEDS A CALL WHEN YOU CAN
HAVE A RIBEYE MADE BY THE SAME
THING THAT PRINTS YOUR EXPENSE
REPORTS.
THE FAKE MEAT COMES FROM A
COMPANY IN SPAIN.
HE TAKES 10 MINUTES TO PRINT,
2 MINUTES TO COOK, ONE MINUTE TO
VOMIT.
THAT SOUNDS LIKE THE NAME OF A
COOL MOVIE.
IT'S BETTER FOR THE ENVIRONMENT.
AS YOU KNOW, THAT TAKES PRIORITY
OVER REAL JOY, GREAT TASTE, OR
HUMAN NEED.
CLAIMING THIS THING LOOKS LIKE
STEAK AND HAS THE SAME
NUTRITIONAL VALUE AND
CONSISTENCY.
MEANING THEY ARE LYING.
IF THAT LOOK LIKE STEAK, I LOOK
LIKE BRAD PITT.
IF THAT LOOKS LIKE STEAK, I'VE
GOT A PAIR OF FLIP-FLOPS THAT
LOOK LIKE STEAK TOO.
IT'S A LIE, LIE MEANT TO HELP
THE PLANET.
IT'S LIKE HOW THEY LIE ABOUT
OTHER FAILED PROMISES.
SOLAR POWER, WINDMILLS,
SOCIALISM.
THINGS WE ARE TOLD TO WORK BUT
CAN ONLY EXIST IF THEY LEECH OFF
GOOD STUFF.
I HAVE A BETTER IDEA.
INCENTIVE 3D PRINTING ESTATE, 3D
PRINTER COW AND THEN KILL IT AND
MAKE STEAKS FROM IT.
I'M WASTING MY TALENTS HERE.
I'M GOING TO SAY THAT EVEN
THOUGH I MADE FUN OF IT, I'M
ACTUALLY FOR THIS IDEA BECAUSE I
LIKE THE IDEA OF MAKING YOUR OWN
FOOD.
IT'S ALMOST LIKE COOKING.
>> Dana: YOU ARE GOING TO WANT
THIS IN YOUR BASEMENT WITH THIS
OTHER FOOD.
I'VE HEARD ABOUT YOUR BASEMENT.
IT'S LIKE AN EASY BAKE OVEN COME
TO LIFE.
ALL THIS STUFF AS KIDS.
I THINK I DIDN'T GET ONE AS A
KID, IT WAS A LATE MODEL.
>> Greg: IT WAS A LIGHT BULB
IN A BOX.
>> Dana: THIS IS A GREAT
INVENTION.
THE BEST KITCHEN INVENTION SINCE
THE MICROWAVE AND I INCLUDE THE
INSTA POT.
>> Jesse: CAN YOU MAKE QUESO
WITH THE 3D PRINTER?
>> Greg: [LAUGHS]
IMAGINE WHAT THAT WOULD LOOK
LIKE.
>> Jesse: I KNOW PRINTERS, AND
THIS THING IS GOING TO JAM RIGHT
BEFORE DINNER.
>> Greg: YOU HAVE TO HAVE A
GUY COME BY.
>> Jesse: THREE DAYS FOR THE
I.T. GUY TO FIX IT.
I DON'T GET IT.
IF YOU DON'T LIKE STEAK, WHY EAT
FAKE STEAK?
IT'S LIKE NONALCOHOLIC BEER.
WHAT'S THE POINT?
>> Greg: IT'S ABOUT FACTORY
FARMING AND CRUELTY TO ANIMALS.
LET'S GO TO THE VEGETARIAN.
>> Dagen: IT IS NOT SUPPOSED
TO TASTE LIKE STEAK.
IT IS SUPPOSED TO HAVE THE --
GOOD VEGAN FOOD HAS THE SAME TO
THEMIS AND BITE OF SOMETHING.
>> Dana: I DIDN'T KNOW THIS.
YOU GAVE ME A RESTAURANT
RECOMMENDATION EARLIER.
>> Dagen: YOU ARE NOT SHAMING
VEGANS.
WHEN I SIT DOWN AND BREAK BREAD
WITH YOU, IF YOU ORDER LAMB, I'M
NOT GOING TO SHOW YOU A PHOTO OF
MY --
>> Greg: YOU ASSUME THAT I
LIKE LAMB.
>> Dagen: I DON'T SHAME PEOPLE
WHO EAT MEAT.
>> Jesse: YOU ARE THE ONLY
PERSON WITH THAT ACCENT THAT IS
A VEGAN.
>> Dagen: WHY IS BEING A VEGAN
SOURCE OF --
A SIGN OF WEAKNESS THAT I CHOOSE
NOT TO EAT AN ANIMAL?
>> Greg: I DON'T SEE IT AS A
SIGN OF WEAKNESS.
I SEE IT AS A CHALLENGE.
I THOUGHT ABOUT DOING IT FOR
THEM I STOPPED THINKING ABOUT
IT.
>> Marie: YOU COULD TRY GIVING
UP MEAT FOR LENT.
>> Jesse: Q HAVE TO BELIEVE IN
LENT FIRST.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: NOW I'M GOING TO GET
LETTERS.
>> Dagen: YOU DO THINK THE 3D
PRINTING IS COOL BECAUSE IT
LOOKS LIKE THIS.
I AM DOING MY BEST JUDY JETSON
IMPERSONATION.
>> Marie: HOW DO THEY MAKE THE
STUFF THAT GOES INTO IT?
>> Greg: I THINK YOU BUY
CARTRIDGES.
LET'S SAY THAT YOU NEED A
CARTRIDGE FOR PIZZA, PASTA.
>> Marie: THERE SOMETHING
ABOUT THE ART OF COOKING.
>> Greg: WHEN YOU HAVE
AUTOMATED COOKING, PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO WANT THE ORGANIC.
>> Dana: I CAN ORDER IT AND
HAVE IT PRINTED OUT BY THE TIME
I GET HOME.
>> Greg: YOU CAN JUST TEXT
PETER.
>> Dagen: YOU ACT LIKE YOU'VE
NEVER EATEN A HOT DOG.
IF YOU HAD SEEN ONE BEING MADE.
>> Marie: THE AMTRAK HOT DOGS
ARE HEBREW NATIONAL.